This is another way
to complete the medical technology that uses the real linen Ganda contained in the
Gundam and release it to the world That means using the Gundam to save lives.
But it's
worth doing
Above all, it's nice to take a different path than my [ __ ] father
I take responsibility I have a
complaint
The company
Gundam
aims to create a medical business using Gundam technology
[Laughter]
Creating a business plan for investors and
distributing PV video
Articles of incorporation and other application documents After the school accepts the student entrepreneurship
application, the
company establishment is complete
[Music]